hello everyone my name is mohit mazunda
and i have 12 years of experience
working and collaborating with pharma
and healthcare industry
to solve high priority scientific
questions related to biomedical data
science and
bioinformatics capacity building as
india mentioned
so some of the things that i would want
to mention before we move on to the
program overview is that the pace at
which firms have
like at this current time the pace at
which firms are
collecting and processing real-time data
is simply astronomic so i would wanted
to give you some examples
like tech farms in asia have developed
mobile apps to help
people check if they have taken the same
flight or train to confirm
uh the virus patients then government
officials are using data to track
individuals
that could use that uses the same data
and many apps are there which uses
infrared and ai powered
facial recognition to screen people at
uh you know
using this sort of data and the same
time
google's deep mind uh is working to find
out about the structures of proteins
that are associated with covid19 so i
think a lot of things are happening with
data and for this
generation of researchers and students
there is an opportunity to discover
from big data and contribute so
in this specialization infectious
diseases program
we will be using curated data sets on
infectious diseases such as malaria
ebola enterovirus uh kovid19
as i said coronavirus host response data
and we will be using public repositories
such as ncbi virus
so in this program we will understand
about the viral diversity
and we will learn about bioinformatics
analysis approaches to study about the
viral genome
and also we will gain hands-on
experience throughout the
sessions that will that i'll be showing
you next
so in these sessions how will we be
using
and analyzing curated data sets um for
which we have already prepared those
example
example projects for you to look at and
gain that experience
and then on top of it you will be guided
by experts
with bioinformatics experience and
knowledge about virology
so the first session uh is scheduled for
18 may so we are going to start the
session
on at the same time so the first session
will be about next generation sequencing
and viral genomes in host transcriptome
and then uh after that the next session
so we have 10 schedule sessions
which will be uh happening over a period
of a month
so the first session is on 18th may the
second session on
is on 20th may and we will be sharing
you the detailed
uh schedule of the program via email as
well and it's also there
on our on our website so if you can if
you want you can look into that
uh after the session as well so the
second session as i was saying it would
be about multiple sequence alignment
and phylogenetic analysis and this will
be followed up by a hands-on session
about preparing and running your own
pipeline so we will be doing multiple
sequence alignment of viral genomes and
then we will be
building phylogenetic trees and then
finding full genome sequences and
preparing those faster files
so all of that will be covered in this
uh third session on 25th
of may and then we have a q a and
discussion of pipeline results so all of
the
data that we will be generating and that
will the results that we'll be getting
getting
we will be analyzing those and
understand the biological significance
or the
uh significance in the context of the
research so
in that sense we will be using and
learning about fasta and fast q files
which data spaces to use for detection
of
uh viral genomes by mapping on those
genomes to
databases and then interpretation of
phylogenetic
phylogenetic interpretation where we are
talking about evolutionary relationships
between genomes and all of that
so after that uh the next session is
about
is about the infection to pandemic so
the viral adaptation here we will be
talking about
hosts and origins so this will be on to
first
june 2021 and
transmission and then cell entry and
tissue
tropism uh after that on
third june we have this session which is
about the symptoms severity
so here we will be talking about the
disease progression
and the outcomes of that how the virus
is replicating and what is the process
of immune invasion and how we can
see that through the data
followed by that we have a hands-on
session again
on 8th june so on 8th june we will be
working on the origin
of human infection with taking examples
and this will be a comparative study
because we will be looking at
um different viruses like mers source
and surge2 and comparing their
their origin by looking at doing the
sequence analysis so this will be on 8th
june as i said
and this will be followed by the next
session which will be on 10th june
so which is about the variance so the
rate of mutation
and how to identify variance what are
the point mutation substitutions
insertions
and about the mutations like what are
the synonymous mutations
what are the non-synonymous mutations
that you are hearing about
so much and also like uh the current
scenario with covid19 and the variant
analysis
uh that is also a part of this program
so uh that will be uh done on 10th
and after that we have the session on
annotation and significance of the
analysis as i was keep on
saying that relating the results that we
get from big data and then
uh you know connecting it to the biology
or to the
analysis results so we'll be looking at
the location on
genome and protein function so that
would be
on 15th june and the same week uh the
next session will be about host pathogen
interaction
where we will be discussing about the
protein protein interaction that elia
discussed
and the host response and the immune
response so
what is happening with the adaptive and
innate immunity
and then about that considering the
bioinformatics
and the holistic understanding of the
system biology considering all what we
have learned
how this can be factored in for you know
vaccine design
how these all plays a role with a data
driven decision
to go for a very specialized sort of
vaccine design that could
uh you know address the problem of the
variants that could address
the problems of uh the changing epitopes
and all of that so that would be on 17th
june
uh so that would be about the schedule
and i'll pause here for a second and
i'll look at if you have any questions
about
these
so if there are no questions here
okay
okay so okay again i just wanted to uh
mention that
the recording of this will be made
available on our youtube channel
and we'll send a follow-up email to
those of you that asked any questions so
some of you asked
for some of the reference publications
or
how to register so that will be shared
by email as apollo
yeah okay thank you and then as i was
saying that once we
have learned about this the next
opportunity as
we've been discussing is to be able to
come up with a research proposal or to
be able to uh
work on a project so this independent
project our research proposal is the
time when we develop within that
period of one month by talking to you by
one-on-one meetings or in a group
meeting and discuss
that how we can uh leverage the uh
online publicly available data sets
and the tools that we have available
here the cloud infrastructure
and to come up with you know research
proposals that could be
new research so
that would be about the program so this
program will con
will consist of several resources and
some of the resources as eli have
already shown
so one of the places that you should go
to is the
learn platform so we have in this entire
omics logic
program have several
has several components so those
components include the training material
data analysis tools curated project
examples
and interactive sessions such as this so
i hope that does
that is clear to everyone that we will
be using multiple resources to come up
and learn about this innovative and new
field of bioinformatics for infectious
diseases so
i think if you have not yet created a
login on the learn platform
so please do that so it's it's a free
free login that you can create
and use some of the free resources that
are there and then
you can also choose to join the
subscriptions that i'll be showing you
the next
next so this program will be utilized
you will also utilize the t-band for
platform
where we will be running the uh running
the analysis big data analysis
and there are several sections as uh you
have already seen many of you have
uh maybe have seen the demonstration i
use the demonstration passwords
uh an email by your own email
so yeah obviously you can do that as
well so
uh also after that we will be utilizing
the coding platform
as discussed uh and we'll be utilizing
some of the
analysis downstream analysis that are
required for us to learn from this data
so this would include the visualization
and getting
uh classification done
for this for different types of texas
so out of this uh entire experience you
will be
able to understand from the scientific
literature uh and describe
that describes the omics data so you'll
be able to
uh perform next generation sequencing
analysis
within uh accuracy and with
reproducibility
and you'll be able to do uh exploratory
data analysis
and generate an hypothesis so that is
something that we discussed
for the projects and then do statistical
analysis
and do some of the machine learning
analysis if required for
you to go into the omics data and find
out those patterns
and then we do the annotation using the
databases that are available online and
then
we find out the relationships and write
about the story and
write about what we have found in our
entire
research project or research
program so that is something that it
will
encompass and other than that i would
like to now take you to the registration
page
which is uh fairly simple
infectiousdiseases.omislogic.com
so here you can click on get started
and then you can here you can choose
from three different levels
so beginners intermediate and advanced
so here you will be able to get
the information about different levels
so the beginner level
uh has all the components that we have
discussed today including all the
licenses that are there and all the
platform access
and all the projects and the difference
between intermediate and beginners
is that you will get an additional
mentor support uh
in the intermediate package and in the
advanced one
if you're working on your own data if
you're working in a lab that is
generating data and you would want to
analyze that which is not available on
public repositories
then you can choose for the advanced
license and
collaborate with us to work on your
research project
so anyways uh to tell you more about the
pricing the cost of this beginners
license one month uh hands-on program is
2 205
and we have a 30 discount code
available on top of it so you can select
here and you can
write the 30 discount code and uh
with that uh that would be the uh that
would be the
price or the cost of this uh program
uh uh provided that you get the early
bird uh scholarship
so uh these are three different methods
that you can
pay through and you can also pay via
bank transfer or upi if you are
if you don't have a card or if you want
that help and assistance
for joining the program